hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be talking
about the real reason why meteo was able
to come back
at this specific point in the story the
further evolution
of deku's quirk abilities bakugou's new
hero name reveal
and what looks like a major momentum
shift on the main battlefield in this
epic war arc boku no hero keeps getting
more and more intense
this is definitely the best arc yet so
let's get into it
if you enjoyed the boku no hero content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going please leave a like and comment
it really does help and if you're new to
anime outpour or you just haven't
subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications it's annoying but
you really gotta go through the trouble
of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss our videos even if you are
subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram
at animeapror finally this video will of
course contain boku no hero manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned the previous
installment of the story had one of the
craziest and most
hyped chapter endings of all time as our
boy
the best boy meteo togata returned
with a fully functioning quirk the
latest chapter begins with meteo
explaining to a shocked deku how he
managed to get his quirk
back now in terms of time in the story
meteo has only been out of commission
for about half a year
but in real world time it's been over
three years
since meteo lost his quirk that actually
happened in chapter 152
which first came out in september of
2017.
so yeah us manga readers have been
waiting for this moment for a very long
time
it turns out that all of our major
speculations were correct because it
was in fact arie who was able to restore
meteosquirk
aerie has been learning to control her
quirk rewind ever since the overhaul arc
and for the past two months in
particular arie has been practicing by
using her mind on lizards and insects
and she has been doing all this in an
attempt to learn to control
and harness her quirk so for example we
see that arie was practicing with a
lizard who had lost
its tail presumably she was able to
rewind
the lizard back to a state where he
still had a tail
even though the missing tail was never
actually reattached
which in itself is freaking crazy when
you think about it
meteo had actually learned in advance
about the big hero raids that would be
taking place in jakku hospital
and the villain mansion so he went to
arie and asked her to please
test out her abilities on him just in
time to actually join
the raid meteo felt bad about asking
arie to do this
he didn't want her to think that he was
just using her for her quirk
but arie was totally cool with it and
she agrees to help medio in the most
adorable way possible in fact arie has
been training
for this very purpose the entire time
she has always wanted to restore myrio's
quirk
after bullets made from her own body had
erased it
and of course miriah lost his quirk
while defending
airy as we can see the risk mirio took
paid off in a big way because
arie was indeed able to restore his
quirk permeation
and make no mistake this was a huge
risk if arie had made one wrong move
she could have killed mirio in an
instant by erasing him out of
existence just like she accidentally did
with her own
father practicing on lizards is one
thing but there is still a lot that
could have gone wrong
with this process and yet meteo chose to
take the risk
he literally risked his life because he
wanted to get his quirk back but not for
some personal reason
he wanted to get his quirk back so that
he can help his fellow heroes
fight against the villains meteo is a
true chad and an amazing hero
and that is why he is probably my
favorite character in the entire series
now as far as we can tell at this time
there have been no negative
repercussions for meteo
after aery used rewind on him although
we shouldn't
rush to judgement rewind is an extremely
overpowered
and unpredictable quirk and its effects
can have
unintended consequences even if we can't
see those consequences right away
aries newfound ability to control her
quirk is actually a huge
deal but the extent to which she can
actually control it
is still a mystery does she already have
perfect control
or could she still make a mistake that
has disastrous consequences
honestly only time will tell at any rate
as meteo continues to fight the nomu so
that best genius can focus on
restraining machia
bakugo returns to the fight in full
force
he uses his explosions to blast the crap
out of the nomu
and in the very next panel which is an
extremely beautiful and action-packed
panel by the way
we learned that nejire is also okay
she does appear to have some serious
burn marks though but she is still on
her feet
and fighting and she is happy to see
that meteo is back in
action and of course we are all happy to
see that nejire
is okay bakugo then proceeds to reveal
his new
official hero name to his mentor best
genius personally i was a huge fan of
king explosion murder
also known as lord explosion murder and
i will continue to stand
that name no matter what happens however
bakugo's new official hero name
is god of destruction dynamite dynamite
is spelled as d-y-n-a-m-i-g-h-t
so the name is a reference to both
dynamite which is an explosive
and to all might who is one of bakugo's
biggest role models
and that's really cool and clever and
all but let's be honest we're all just
gonna keep calling him either bakugou or
kachan no one is gonna be like oh hey
look it's our boy god of destruction
dynamite
no we're gonna be like hey it's bakugo
now meteo
actually likes bakugo's new name because
it's funny but bakugo is like
dude it's not supposed to be funny
bakugo is not exactly known for his
sense of humor
but meteo explains that laughter and joy
are an essential component of being
a hero so there's nothing wrong with
having a funny hero name
and yes my boy medio is right and that
is exactly why
bakugou should have just stuck with king
explosion murder
but whatever moving on as all of this is
happening in
one section of the battlefield dobby and
shoto are still
fighting not too far away an endeavor is
still just kind of watching it all with
a look of shock
and despair at the moment endeavor seems
to be unable to do anything other than
stare helplessly as two of his sons are
fighting a bitter battle to the death
during the battle shoto actually warns
dobby that he is
overusing his quirk and that his entire
body will burn up
but dobby doesn't care dobby loves the
look of despair
on endeavour's face and he is determined
to kill
shoto right in front of endeavour
because he really wants to see
endeavour's face
after his greatest toy shoto is
destroyed by his
own flames i talked about this before
but
dobby is truly obsessed with his desire
to get revenge on endeavor
and i mean obsessed in a mentally
disturbed way that obstructs
all reason and logic i mean dobby
clearly knows that shoto
is not responsible for what endeavor has
done and dobby also knows that shoto is
his own brother
and yet dabi wants to make endeavour
suffer so badly that he is willing to
kill his own brother
his own brother who is innocent just to
make endeavors suffer that
is really messed up and as i said before
it is also hypocritical
the whole reason why endeavour became
abusive to his family and to dobby in
particular
was his own obsession with surpassing
all might
endeavour's obsession destroyed his
family and tore it apart
and now dobby's obsession with revenge
is doing the exact same thing
it is a truly sad and ironic turn of
events
but sadly life is full of irony
thankfully deku is able to intervene in
the fight
and get dobby away from shoto before
shoto is burnt to a crisp
by dabi's flames even though deku
doesn't have any strength left in his
arms and legs
he is able to unleash black whip from
his mouth
froppy style and he uses the black whip
coming from his mouth
in order to keep dobby away from shoto
it is definitely cool seeing deku
learning from froppy's techniques
and using black whip in the same way
that she uses her tongue
but i'll be real with you i did not see
this coming
dekku using a black whipped tongue
attack was not
on my list of things that are going to
happen in 2020 and that's saying
something given the kind of year that
we've had
still this little moment is an important
reminder that all of these hero students
will continue to train
and work together and as they do they
will be able to learn from each other
and make each other stronger and these
skills and techniques that they learn
from each other may
one day save their lives when dobby
tells dekku not to meddle in the affairs
of the todoroki family
deku says that shoto is his precious
friend and that endeavor
is an important mentor even though the
bad things that endeavour has done in
the past
won't just disappear endeavour is
clearly making an effort to become
a better person and this endeavor who is
trying to make amends
is the kind of man that deku can respect
and appreciate
however dobby isn't affected in the
least by deku's words
dobby firmly believes that endeavor
deserves to pay for everything that he
has done
and along with endeavor the entire hero
society also deserves to pay
for his sins once all of japan learns
that the number one pro hero is actually
a terrible person
faith in heroes will plummet justice
will crumble
and chaos will reign this is something
that dobby believes in very deeply
something that he has been working
towards for years and so he absolutely
refuses to even consider the possibility
that endeavor has changed or improved
as a person in the very next moment
machia's power surges yet again and he
is able to break through
genius cables the heroes prepare for
what appears to be
big big trouble and endeavour suddenly
snaps out of his despair
and leaps into the air even endeavour
despite everything that he is going
through right now
emotionally knows that if makia starts
moving again he has to act
but then machia starts feeling numb
suddenly machia collapses back down to
the ground
and this time it's not because of the
cables momo's anesthetic
that sleeping agent that kirishima was
able to throw inside of makia's mouth
appears to be finally taking effect
at this point it looks like machia is
going to be out of commission for the
foreseeable future
and this really turns the tables once
again in
this fight this definitely gives the
heroes additional hope that they can win
this battle
after all and even though dobby and the
nomu are still very much
in the game the two biggest villain
threats
shigaraki and machia are currently
unable to fight i mean at least for now
but the situation keeps changing all the
time
and that is how this chapter ends and if
you're now thinking that
oh okay this fight might finally be
coming to an end i wouldn't be so sure
the fact that meteor returned and the
fact that endeavour seems to have gotten
it together
are both great news for the heroes as
well as the fact that negede is okay
and the fact that bakugou appears to be
in fighting shape yet again
and with both shigaraki and makia
currently indisposed
yeah it definitely looks good for the
heroes at the moment
but don't forget that shigaraki could
recover at any
moment once his super regeneration kicks
in again
dobby of course is more determined than
ever to destroy the heroes
using his flames which are even more
powerful than endeavors and let's not
forget that toga
is also out there somewhere i could
totally see
toga coming in clutch for the villains
at just the right moment
and i wouldn't be surprised if she
turned herself into twice
and used sad man's parade to turn the
tables on the heroes
yet again there have already been so
many crazy twists and turns during this
battle
and i firmly believe that this is not
the end of the fight
no matter how good things look for the
heroes right now
will machia actually stay down for good
and will shigaraki be able to recover in
time to continue the fight oh and what
about
dobby is dobby going to continue
fighting shoto even if makia and all the
nomu
are defeated are the villains about to
be forced into a retreat
or will the momentum shift once again
maybe as a result of toga's awakened
quirk
do not forget to leave your thoughts and
feedback down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more boku no hero content right
here on the channel please leave a like
to let me know
it really does help and if you're new to
anime out pro
or maybe you just haven't had a chance
to subscribe make this the video that
you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications
it's really important to click that bell
and select the option that says all
if you don't do that youtube is still
going to hide our videos from you
it's just the way it works you can also
hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible
a special thank you to alpha sigma a
disciple
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
all of our the one
tier patrons including ingrata the world
acquired respect
liam thompson pate heffa rythian yx
emperor otaku thomas jones spidey life
chanel
baked buddhist tungsten tarkis and denki
kaminari
and finally thanks to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp
joe stanton rathune de oro very gucci
jessica calefon
alicia octor hinokami and water bonnie
parks the red-haired raven florian joy
and garcia mcshamus
jack watches anime amanda c deadly saint
high school dxd73 matthew cruz and
anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya space
[Music]
cowboys
[Music]
you